wir sehen doch dass Deutschland auf dem
nieder auf dem absteigenden Ast ist wir
sehen eine Insolvenzwelle die uns jetzt
schon tot und auch natürliche Idee
Industrialisierung wir sehen Krisen in
unglaublichen Maße wir sehen die
Inflation wir sind die Rezession wir
sehen Energiekrise und jetzt auch noch
Politiker die völlig überfordert sind
und von einer Krise zur nächsten hecheln
und wirklich keine Krise lösen ganz im
Gegenteil teilweise sogar verschlimmern
durch ihre Aktionen und natürlich
belasten uns Bürger die Energie und
Strompreise immens aber natürlich auch
die deutsche Wirtschaft und die deutsche
Wirtschaft ist am klagen und warnt vor
einer Insolvenz weil und warnt vor einer
den Industrialisierung wir haben BASF
gesehen die gesagt haben sie werden
nicht mehr in Europa investieren das ist
ein Alarmsignal bei BASF ist an der
Hauptarbeitgeber in Deutschland extrem
wichtig und wir sehen dass immer mehr
Unternehmen überlegen abzuwandeln ihre
Produktion zu verlagern um günstige
Energie zu haben um eine
Versorgungssicherheit zu haben und vor
allem eine Planbarkeit weil die fehlt
weil wir haben eine Politik die jeden
Tag eine andere Idee hat und wir sehen
ja dass die Sanktionen uns massiv
Schaden und deswegen versuchen die
ersten Unternehmen nach ins Ausland zu
gehen bzw ihre Produktion zu verlagern
gehen in Kurzarbeit und parallel
natürlich gibt es auch viele Unternehmen
die jetzt in die Insolvenz gehen müssen
weil sie die Energie und Strompreise
nicht mehr bezahlen können und jetzt
muss die Politik unbedingt aktiv werden
bevor hier auch unser sozialer Frieden
und nicht unser Wohlstand auf dem Spiel
stehen weil die Menschen werden auf die
Straße gehen darüber nach mit Herrn
patzeltreten aber tatsächlich ist es so
dass es jetzt um die Existenz um die
Zukunft Deutschlands geht und da gibt es
verschiedene Sachen die man jetzt
angehen muss also natürlich muss die
Politik handeln stimme ich Ihnen
vollkommen zu warum wollen Sie jetzt an
die Sanktionen gegen Russland ran das
hatte ich für einen schweren Fehler also
wollen sie jetzt im Ernst sagen jawohl
wir beziehen wieder mehr Gas aus wir
machen trotzdem zwei ist jetzt ja eh in
die luftgesprungen so aber
das kann ja nicht das kann ja eigentlich
nicht ernst sein also was so soll der
Westen jetzt einfach zuschauen wie
Russland wie Putin in der Ukraine
Zivilisten regelrecht da muss man sagen
abschlachtet das kann nicht sein
Wirtschaftssanktionen sind ein starkes
Instrument dass wir sozusagen gewaltfrei
einsetzen können gegen Diktator Vladimir
Putin und das sollten wir unbedingt auch
tun auch wenn es uns möglicherweise in
bestimmte Maße auch schade ich glaube
aber auch es schadet uns mehr
nachweislich als Russland Putin hat noch
nie mehr Geld verdient mit seinen
Exporten von Öl und Gas wie aktuell
Gazprom hat ein Rekordgewinn verbucht
also der der Rubel rollt muss man
tatsächlich Leiter sagen und wir leiten
darunter wir sehen dass die deutsche
Industrie immer mehr echt und dass sie
auch schon versuchen ins Ausland
abzuwandern das ist eine große Gefahr
und wir können Wohlstand mehr haben dann
können wir auch die Ukraine nicht
unterstützen wir können nicht die grüne
Transformation vorantreiben wir können
kein Bürgergeld implementieren es muss
uns allen klar sein und die Sanktion zu
beenden ist nur ein Punkt den ich
kritisiere ist mir viele weitere Punkte
wir müssen jetzt die Ideologie ad acta
legen weil wir hatten es jahrelang
eigentlich eine Art verblendeten
Dogmatismus in der Politik also
Atomausstieg eine völlig überhastete
Energiewende die definitiv geschaltet
ist ein Trümmerhaufen ist die bankrotte
Erklärung schlechthin die wir gerade
erleben sondern dass wir jetzt den
Pragmatismus und den Schutz der Bürger
und der Bevölkerung des sozialen
Friedens über diese Ideologien stellen
das wird sagen wir müssen einfach neue
Wege beschreiben die Atomenergie die ist
nicht emissionslos und grün geadelt von
der EU nein die ist auch hoch effizient
Ideologie Adapter gehe ich mit aber
trotzdem gegen Putin sollten wir tun was
immer wir können das hatte ich für
richtig das liegt lieber auf lngas
Setzen von mir aus sogar und so weiter
aber nicht putin ist so das Geld in die
klassenspülen damit er diesen Wahnsinn
passt weil wir kaufen das Öl von Putin
trotzdem halt über Drittländer wie zum
Beispiel bei China ist ja völlig absurd
aber wir können lange drüber reden fakt
ist ich glaube nicht dass
Waffenlieferung im Krieg ähm beenden am
Sanktion kann man darüber reden ich
glaube nur die Sanktionen haben uns mehr
geschadet der westlichen Welt als sie
Russland geschadet haben
welche Zahlen anschaut sehe ich einfach
rekordsteuereinnahmen Rekord Umsätze mit
Öl Gas und anderen Rohstoffen die
Russland gerade verbuchten dann auch
eins zu eins wieder in die
Kriegswirtschaft in finanzieren kann das
ganze Paradies Russland was sie in der
beschreiben das höre ich also deutlich
anders also da kommt glaube
158 Milliarden im zweiten Quartal aber
das Einnahmen die russische Wirtschaft
getroffen wurde von den Sanktionen das
stimmt also aktiven Fakt es ist ja nicht
so als hätte die russische Wirtschaft
der ging es jetzt besser als vor den
Sand zu das stimmt nicht wir wurden
selbstverständlich auch getroffen aber
da gehe ich hier auch mit dass die
russische Wirtschaft natürlich schon
leidet und es gibt auch Experten die
sagen es wird länger dauern bis die in
Gänze wirken die Sanktionen aber die
Frage an Herrn Patzelt die ich noch sehr
sehr spannend finde ist natürlich die
Deindustrialisierung Deutschlands kommt
es jetzt wirklich nur durch die
Sanktionen ist es nicht schon ein viel
längeres Vorspiel hat es jetzt wirklich
nur der Ukraine Krieg ausgelöst dass wir
eigentlich als Wirtschaft immer
schwächer werden das Problem ist dass
hier viele Fehlentscheidungen und
Fehlentwicklung der Vergangenheit
zusammenkommen oben drauf gibt es die
extreme Verteuerung der Energiepreise
die nun Aluminium und Hersteller
chemische Industrie
betrifft Deutschland wir waren bei den
Energiepreisen ein sehr
wettbewerbsfähiges Land wozu nicht
zuletzt unsere turmkraftwerke beim Strom
und eben auch das billige Gas aus
Russland beigetragen hat und hey das ist
nun durch politische Entscheidungen
unterbunden weder gibt es billiges Gas
aus Russland noch wollen wir
Atomkraftwerke weiter laufen lassen aber
es kommen noch weitere Entscheidungen
oder fehlentwickeln dazu es ist zum
einen die schon auf die späten 60er
frühen 70er Jahre zurück in der
Vorstellung dass im Grunde die Industrie
es ist die unser Leben bedroht wir haben
einen zu großen ökologischen Fußabdruck
wir machen zu viele Emissionen es ist
die Industrie die sozusagen viel an
Lebensqualität verhindert da kommen
deutsche romantische Vorstellungen von
waldluftwiese alles grün die Sonnenblume
ist er nicht umsonst ein so ikonisches
Zeichen der Grünen geworden wir wollen
zurück zur Natur die rauchenden Schlote
dürfen nicht mehr sein der blaue Himmel
über dem Ruhrgebiet ist Gott sei Dank
inzwischen erreicht aber es müssen wir
die Restbestände an Industrie beseitigen
das ist es aber auch noch nicht
ganz wesentlich ist das
Ausbildungssystem Industrie können Sie
nur dann betreiben wenn sie Facharbeiter
haben Facharbeiter brauchen
Verlässlichkeit Ausdauer unser
Ausbildungssystem in Deutschland war ja
eigentlich lange Jahre von vielen
Ländern auch beneidet also es
Ausbildungssystem in Deutschland war ja
wirklich einzigartig in der
Vergangenheitsform aber wenn Sie sich
ansehen was die etlichen
bildungsreformungen in Deutschland am
10% Abbrecherquote bei den Ausbildungen
Deutschland eben Abbrecherquoten
Schenkung des Bildungsniveaus bei
Rechtschreibung will ich gar nicht reden
wie es aussieht kopfrechnung im Maler
Berufen vielleicht nicht ganz unnötig um
auszurechnen wie viele Farbe man für
welche Quadratmeterzahl braucht können
einen auch können einem auch
Schreckensgeschichte erzählt werden und
im Bildungssystem haben wir die
Vorstellung durchgesetzt das eigentlich
der Mensch erst ab dem Akademiker
beginnt das heißt Facharbeiter oder gar
Zuarbeiter das kommt nicht in Frage und
wenn sie dann auch noch den Lohndruck
und den abgabendruck und den Bürokratie
Druck auf die Unternehmen zu erhöhen wie
das in Deutschland der Fall ist kann
haben sie sozusagen das gesamte
Horrorszenario beisammen damit haben sie
ja die falsche Anspruchshaltung
angesprochen jeder muss studieren
Ausbildung ist nichts mehr wert aber
frisch vielleicht wird sie gerne mal
fragen ist es vielleicht auch so zu viel
Gender Studies zu also zu wenig
Ingenieurwesen zu viel Gender Studies ja
ich glaube dass das Thema
Naturwissenschaften und Mathematik in
Deutschland einfach total unterbewertet
wird es ist hier bei uns immer noch
schick sein zu können in Mathe war ich
immer schlecht oder mit Statistik kann
ich nichts anfangen ja und das wird mit
dazu dass wir die Digitalisierung in
Deutschland einfach verschlafen und ich
finde ihn ganz wichtigen Punkt
Digitalisierung
datendatenwissenschaften heißt nicht nur
Akademiker was wir nicht geschafft haben
ist in unserer Ausbildungssystem
genügend neue Berufe zur einzuführen die
sich mit Daten und Digitalisierung
auseinandersetzen denn es braucht nicht
nur studierte datenwissenschaftler um
mit dem Thema Digitalisierung und Daten
umzugehen und hier die Wirtschaft
voranzubringen ins 21 Jahrhundert
sondern wir brauchen da auch sehr sehr
viele Fachkräfte dafür haben wir aber
keine entsprechenden Ausbildungsberufe
und wenn nicht mehr überlegt wie lange
es dauert einen neuen Ausbildungsberuf
bei der IHK einzuführen da können wir
mal locker mit fünf Jahren rechnen ja
und dann ich meinte das die Technologie
schon wieder veraltet ja dann brauchen
wir eigentlich schon wieder den nächsten
und das haben wir total verschlafen und
da müssen wir wirklich auch dieses
System wie schaffen wie halten wir
eigentlich Schritt mit der Entwicklung
neuer Technologien und passen unser
Bildungssystem entsprechend an diesen
Schritt den haben wir den müssen wir
auch schaffen heute kam auch noch eine
andere Studie raus und zwar es wird
jedem fünften Kind in Deutschland nicht
mehr vorgelesen also jedes fünfte Kind
in Deutschland kommt nicht mehr in den
Genuss deswegen vorgelesen wird anhand
der Zahl Sebastian Geister sind
vielleicht auch die Eltern damit schon
in der Erziehung schuld dass Deutschland
immer weiter abdriftet egal wo steigert
hat mal das Buch schon früh geschrieben
Abstieg eines Superstars es gibt ganz
viele Faktoren also wenn man allein
bedingt wenn Menschen ständig junge
Menschen am Internet hätten am hängen am
Handy Instagram die
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne die immer geringer
wird immer nur für irgendwelche kleinen
Schnipselchen nur noch reicht das ist
glaube ich sehr schädlich
akademisierungswahn gehe ich voll mit
also warum ist das ist das notig wir
hatten ein sehr gutes Ausbildungssystem
in Deutschland ich würde sagen
Meisterbrief ist eigentlich mehr wert
als die mal also als zahlreiche
Maßnahmen ja ja oder so Handwerk hat
goldene Boden das sehen wir jetzt haben
wir die den Fachkräftemangel wir
produzieren und wurde eher arbeitslose
Akademiker vielfach es kann nicht jeder
gender aber beauftragte werden Gott sei
Dank auch meistens mehr Handwerker
verdientes Geld wenn sie am Ende
vielleicht sogar eigene Betrieb haben
und so weiter schaffen selbst
Arbeitsplätze das ist was damit kann man
durchaus gutes Auskommen haben ich würde
sogar fast sagen manche können reich
werden damit das ist eigentlich sehr
attraktive sollten das attraktiver
machen und die Menschen auch besser
ausbilden und nicht Leute in solche
Orchideen Fächern an der Uni schicken
Gender Studies zu sein Unsinn aber die
werden sich durch die kommende Krise auf
jeden Fall auflösen weil ich glaube
tatsächlich dass Deutschland vor der
größten Krefeld den Zweiten Weltkrieg
steht durch die insolvenzqualität droht
durch die die Industrialisierung durch
die Unternehmen der Mensch dann der
meistens durchschaut und haben vorhin
darüber gesprochen da die die Menschheit
es hat jeher eigentlich geprägt durch
Krisen und Krisen bringen einen weiteren
eigenen Biografie schauen man hat mit
den größten Lerneffekt die erste Fünf in
Mathe bei ihnen ne oder
die erste enttäuschte Liebe und so
weiter das heißt anscheinend ja wir
müssen wir müssen ja wir müssen
wahrscheinlich erst scheitern bevor wir
dann wirklich neue Wege einschlagen und
es ist nicht einfach weil jetzt muss man
diese Ideologie teilweise über Bord
werfen müssen neue Wege beschreiben
vielleicht müssen wir über Fracking
reden vielleicht müssen wir über
Kohleabbau wieder reden den wir erst
zuvor mit Milliarden an Subventionen
beerdigt haben also wir müssen ja die
Energieversorgung sicherstellen aber wir
sind ein energieintensives Land wir
haben Wirtschaft wie Papier Glas Metall
Automobilbau die brauchen Energie muss
auch günstig im wettbewerbsfähig sind
ansonsten müssen wir den Wohlstand
einfach ad-winken und dann kann man das
Bürgergeld auch gleich Adapter legen
weil dann ist ja Ende Gelände